with him software
I remember as a man who but
always defended the rights of citizens of Russia to
of the end I fought for these rights
wars of war in ukraine the idea of ​​boris was
to prove to everyone that we are
involved in beer not
and if we we recognize it and the people how would
stand up against this then war vova not
will be saved was against the war i don't think
what is the direct order of the Kremlin I think it
some fanatics who are not behind
the last time has spawned a lot
system when anyone committing
will report the enemy but found some
wishing group wishing
I just understand that now
going on it went too far and
need to somehow weaken can be in
some things back and fresh
look at all that
happens and really sorry for something
something to change
Putin